this is a production of cornell
university
thanks for joining us today i hope
you've been able to hear the previous
hour
when jennifer whiteman provided an
introduction to the topic of greenhouse
gas emissions in agriculture
both of these presentations will be
recorded and available
online
i'm going to talk about some specific
soil health practices
and
using an example of the fast greenhouse
gas tool and a few key research results
to talk about how
we can think about soil health practices
and their effects on net greenhouse gas
emissions
there are lots of options for reducing
greenhouse gas emissions in agriculture
and i hope you uh were able to hear
jennifer's previous talk where she went
through quite a number of these
i'm going to focus on the bottom four
here that are highlighted in in
red font
i'm going to be focusing on
commodity crop production in new york
state but a lot of these results are
relevant for some other cropping systems
and certainly for other states as well
so the fast greenhouse gas tool is
something we developed to estimate
greenhouse gas emissions
from some of the most important
commodity crops
in the u.s
sorry i
and some of the most important soil
health practices
this is available as an open source
online calculator at the website listed
here and i also put that in the chat box
as well
it includes cover crops tillage and
nitrogen fertilizer management for corn
soybean and wheat in the usa
so it is important to recognize this as
a national tool
so some of the most important aspects of
this tool
our goal is to account for the impact of
management practices so we're really
interested in what is the change in
greenhouse gases uh going from
kind of a conventional practice to an
improved soil health practice
we also wanted to make a tool that's
that will work with little or no farm
specific data
i apologize for the slides advancing i
seem to have them automatically set
so i'll be bouncing back and forth a
little bit
we wanted to be able to make estimates
with little or no farm specific data so
we used soils data for every county in
the country and and yield data as well
we wanted this tool to be grounded in a
mechanistic understanding of of how
carbon and nitrogen actually function in
soils
at the same time we wanted to be
grounded in the results of long-term
field experiments so trying to make it
as realistic as possible
for production agriculture
and lastly it's publicly available and
it's thoroughly documented so you can
look under the hood and see what's
happening
this is what the
initial screen of the tool looks like
so on the left there's a limited number
of choices that you can make
to use the tool for different crops and
practices
and on the right we have you start with
the results tab where the results will
be shown
once you choose your crop in practice
so the first step in using the tool
is to select the state and the county
that you're interested in and also the
crop
the next step is to choose the practices
that you'll implement so you can
implement one or more practices
and within each of these practices there
are a few different choices for example
for cover crops you can choose a legume
a non-legume or a mixed
a mixture of legume and non-legume
i'm going to go through four examples
for corn
cover crop legume cover crop on
non-legume cover crop
precision nitrogen fertilizer management
and reduced tillage all of these
examples
i will
will be for tompkins county where the
live
uh portion of this meeting is taking
place today
and this is all corn for grain
okay so here are the results and i'm
going to walk walk through this in some
detail here because the layout of these
results will be the same for each of
these
examples
in summary
at the
at the bottom of the
chart is the total in green
so this total is showing that a legume
cover crop
the tool is estimating
that on average across many farms and
many years a legume cover crop will
decrease net greenhouse gas emissions
so the positive values here indicate a
decrease because the tool again is
focused on what is the greenhouse gas
benefit
of using this practice
so
the total bar as i just mentioned is
below in green
and that's showing the megagrams or
metric tons of carbon dioxide emissions
per hectare per year
so you can see right away that the tool
is using scientific units not english
units
the rest of the bars above the green bar
show the different categories of
greenhouse gas emission that are being
estimated
so the top one is nitrous oxide
emissions
so a legume cover crop will decrease
nitrous oxide emissions
the next one down is nitrogen fertilizer
production
and again this practice is reducing
emissions from the fertilizer production
so this is
indicating nitrogen fertilizer inorganic
nitrogen fertilizer has a lot of
greenhouse gas emissions due to the
production it requires a lot of energy
and there are also nitrous oxide
emissions with the production
so if we can reduce fertilizer use
we reduce the emissions of nitrous oxide
in the field but we also reduce the
upstream emissions of nitrous oxide
the next
topic is leakage and that's zero and
i'll talk about that later with another
example where it's not zero
the inputs we see here is actually a
negative value the bar is going to the
left
and that indicates there's actually an
increase in greenhouse gas emissions
with inputs and the reason for this is
there are some emissions associated with
producing cover crop seed
and and everything else that's required
to successfully grow the cover crop
there the next topic is inputs from
tillage this is zero because in this
example we made no change in tillage
the next one
category is fuel for the cover crops
so
planting the cover crops does require
additional tractor passes
and there are emissions associated with
that
now if you heard jennifer whiteman's
previous talk we have to be careful with
greenhouse gas accounting
at the state and national level
fuel emissions from tractors
are counted in the
in the energy sector and not in the
agriculture sector
that's an accounting convention that's
designed to make sure
that nothing gets double counted and
nothing gets missed
however if we are interested in the
impact of a soil health practice on
total greenhouse gas emissions
it's important to include
that energy
the the
emissions from the tractor passes
as well as including
these upstream emissions from fertilizer
manufacturer which also would typically
in an inventory not be counted in the
agriculture sector
the last component of the total
so the bottom gray bar here is soil
organic carbon
so we see this is a benefit here
for this practice so when we use a
legume cover crop we're increasing soil
organic carbon
but this the important thing here is
we're not focusing on any one of these
factors
not just nitrous oxide not just soil
carbon change
but instead we're adding them all
together to see the net
benefit
the next
example is a non-legume cover crop
and here we see a red bar for the total
at the bottom
and there's actually an increase in
greenhouse gas emissions when we use a
non-legume cover crop again this is a
prediction the model's making
an average
across many farms and many fields
now why is this happening so here again
we look above at the gray bars to see
where did the total come from
and we see that most of these categories
actually cause an increase in emissions
the only category
that shows
a benefit is the soil carbon
sequestration
so we're getting a benefit of soil
carbon sequestration
but we're getting an increase in nitrous
oxide emissions now this is not
may not be intuitive why is this
happening
the reason this is happening is
based on farmer's practices and many
extension recommendations
we think it's likely that there'll be
actually additional nitrogen fertilizer
used when a non-legume cover crop is
used to make sure there's adequate
nitrogen available for the main crop
so there's an increase in fertilizer use
which increases nitrous oxide emissions
here and also increases
there's some emission from the
production of the fertilizer
and again as for the
legume cover crop
there are some emissions associated with
inputs for the cover crop and fuel for
the cover crop
again we look at all these different
components together
and there's actually an increase in
greenhouse gas emissions
however this is relatively small
it's less than a tenth of
a ton
of carbon dioxide equivalents per
hectare per year
and there are many we can imagine many
variations on how the practice is
implemented and the cropping system that
would affect these results
the third example is precision nitrogen
management
so here we're talking about using
[Music]
sophisticated tools to really dial back
and make sure we're applying just the
amount of fertilizer that's needed at
the right time
when the crop can use it
so here it's all good
the total at the bottom
shows a benefit a decrease in greenhouse
gas emissions
and the decrease is due to a decrease in
the direct nitrous oxide emissions and
that's because we're using less
fertilizer
so we're getting a better efficiency
more of the nitrogen that's applied is
being taken up by the crop there's less
that's available to be lost as nitrous
oxide or leached as as nitrate or lost
in any other way
and again we're getting a benefit where
we're using less fertilizer so we're
reducing emissions associated with the
production of that fertilizer as well
the last corn example here is no-till
and as shown in the total
green bar at the bottom again there's a
net benefit here of this practice
of about
a tenth of
a
metric ton of carbon dioxide equivalents
per year
and most of this impact is actually from
what
is it from soil carbon sequestration
well there is a benefit
of soil carbon sequestration here but
there's a much larger benefit
from reducing
the tractor passes
and this gets into the issue of
permanence
so we we include in this tool a discount
uh because soil carbon sequestration may
not be permanent in other words if we do
no-till for 10 years
but then we go back to a
full tillage
for several years after that we've lost
we can lose all of the carbon that's
been sequestered in the soil so that the
tool discounts this
by a factor of of a half
so if we kept up this practice for a
hundred years the soil carbon benefit
would be greater
the last example i'll give using the
fast greenhouse gas tool
is
is wheat and again this is also in
tompkins county
and some information about the crop
yield and nitrogen rate are are shown
here
for all of these examples have been on a
silt loam soil
so for the wheat no-till example
we get an increase in greenhouse gas
emissions
so that's shown at the red bar
for the total at the bottom
well how did this happen if we look
above at the gray bars they're all over
the place
there are
there are four of them which provide a
benefit
so we're getting a reduction in nitrous
oxide emissions
a reduction in fertilizer production
a reduction in fuel use and a benefit of
increased soil carbon
but we're getting this big leakage term
now what does that actually mean
well this leakage is happening because
long-term field experiments in the u.s
have shown that often no-till
can cause a a small decrease in yield
for wheat
of about four percent
so when we have a decrease in yield
it's not causing any greenhouse gas
emission directly in this field
however
at the global scale
if we reduce production of wheat in the
u.s it's very likely to increase
somewhere else in the world
and there can be large emissions
of greenhouse gases associated with an
increase in production wherever it
occurs
think about in some cases forests are
cut down and burned to create new crop
land and there are a lot of emissions
associated with that
even though that only happens on a small
fraction of global cropland
so leakage is a
so what leakage means
is
that a change in in our location that
we're interested in in a specific field
or a specific state or country
causes
a shift in greenhouse gas emissions to
another location
and and it's important to account for
that kind of a problem
although it's challenging to do so it's
important not to leave this out of the
equation as we can see here it's
actually the largest impact of anything
here
and it's causing the total to be
a small increase in greenhouse gas
emissions
now clearly
farmers are not interested in a yield
decrease
and if we could eliminate the yield
decrease in this example we would switch
the sign of the the total right
it would become positive there'd be a
net greenhouse gas benefit if we didn't
have a yield decrease
so now i'm going to talk a little bit
more about
some other aspects
of the tool that you might like to
explore so there's some optional
advanced inputs that are very important
right at the bottom here
it says show advanced inputs
and if you click on that button
you get a few options a really important
one is crop yield so this is a way you
can put
field specific
or farm specific information
as an input to the tool and we expect
that if you're using farm specific
information
you should get a better
a result that's more relevant for your
farm or field
this is especially important because as
i mentioned this is a national tool
and so the the
national values for nitro inorganic
nitrogen fertilizer use
are are used in this tool that are
published by the economic research
service but those don't account for the
fact
that there's a lot of manure used in new
york state
so we recommend in new york state always
using the advanced input option
and putting in
putting in
an appropriate nitrogen fertilizer rate
the last option here under advanced
inputs
is
your estimate of this discount factor
for whether whether cover cropping will
be continued indefinitely or whether
there's some chance that it might be
discontinued
so this is over a hundred years
now this seems kind of crazy right a
farmer or any of us cannot predict
what someone will be doing a hundred
years from now
but this points out the challenge here
of practices that are not permanent
when we're trying to address the issue
of climate change which is important on
scales of decades to centuries to
thousands of years
so if we don't have permanence for at
least 100
years then we're getting less of a
benefit in mitigating climate change
as i mentioned previously
we set this
at 50 that there's a 50 that once you
start cover cropping you'll keep it'll
continue to occur on that field
for a hundred years
but you can change that value here if
you could somehow guarantee it would be
a hundred percent
you can input that value
there's also other information available
from the tool so if you hover your arrow
when you're using the tool over
something like tillage practice you get
a pop-up window that defines the three
practices that you can choose from
there's also other information available
from some different tabs above the graph
here
so here we've so far just looked at the
results tab
which shows the graph of results
it's empty here because no
practices have been selected but there
are other tabs here
for example the calculations tab that
allows you to
see a lot of information about what's
going on
in in creating these
estimates from the tool
so if you click on that tab
it shows you your user inputs
so you can confirm yes that's what i
intended to
to put in there
below that it also shows what's called
derived parameters
so given the inputs that you provided
and a lot of information that's stored
in the tool about soil
crop yields
and fertilizer rates
and many other things
this shows you many of the values that
are calculated in the model
so you can see if you think they're
appropriate for your
situation and then below those
parameters it shows the results of
calculations so
if you wanted the exact values
for the breakdown of your results you
can get them here
and you can also in in this uh for
example you could see that four percent
yield decrease from the wheat uh example
that would show up in in
this internal uh
this tab there's also
thorough documentation available from
the website so you can download this pdf
file and read about the equations the
assumptions and the data that are used
in the model
this tool like any similar tool has
limitations
as i mentioned the default fertilizer
rate for new york should not be used for
most purposes
instead you should use the advanced
inputs option and define the nitrogen
rate
and you should also define the yield if
you have that information
like other tools it can't include all
the variation among farms and practices
there are a limited number of crops and
a limited number of practices that are
included and those are included because
they're important crops
important practices and there are enough
data about them to make
[Music]
robust predictions
so how should this tool be used
so what are some of the uses of it and
limitations of the results of the tool
so this yes this tool can be used to
help identify benefits and challenges
with greenhouse gas mitigation
strategies
and yes it can be used to compare
results from long-term experiments
to look for differences
so maybe you have a good estimate for
one portion of like maybe you have good
data on soil carbon sequestration
maybe from some long-term experiments
maybe from some farm specific data
but you need an estimate for some of the
other components of the net greenhouse
gas emission
so you can use those you could combine
those together
you might also have results from along
in terms of research
and
making improvements in the future
experimental results might differ from
this and that should cause you to think
about is there an issue with the
experiment or is there an issue with the
model
so limitations of the tool
it cannot be used to make a specific
quantum quantitative prediction of
benefit for a specific farm
the intent is to make a prediction of
the average across many farms and many
years
and it can't be used as a verification
of of a mitigation from an activity so
we do not recommend that this or similar
tools be used
uh to
as a verification for example in a
carbon market situation
so that concludes
the portion of my talk using the fast
greenhouse gas tool
as a way to talk about net greenhouse
gas emissions and as a way for us to
think about
some of the different sources of those
emissions and how they add up
next i'm going to talk
a little more about
some of these management practices
and show a little bit of data from a
long-term field experiment
so reducing excess nitrogen inputs is a
large part of greenhouse gas benefits so
i'm going to spend a little time on this
topic
one point i want to make is reducing
nitrous oxide emissions
is permanent
so if we reduce fertilizer use
for a crop without reducing yield
that's a permanent reduction in the
nitrous oxide emission
uh both in the field and and from the
factory so it's not reversible
in the way that storing carbon and soil
is can be reversed with a change in
practice
if you stop
if you apply excess nitrogen again you
will have a misadmission associated with
that
that excess in that year
but it won't change the result of what
you did the previous year
and then of course we need to keep in
mind that we're not managing soils and
crops primarily for greenhouse gas
reduction
so
there are many reasons to add organic
matter to soil as many of you very well
know
there are many reasons that that's
really critically important
depending on your farm situation
so we want some of these uh benefits
from organic matter edition
in this talk we're just focusing on the
greenhouse gas
aspect
of that
so this graph shows for different crops
the
greenhouse gas emissions
estimated for for new york state
and this was done for a bioenergy
analysis
so the only one i want to focus on is
just the maize or corn the tallest bar
here
and this is showing
that the total emissions is in
categories here so the largest total
emission is the light pink
and that's the direct nitrous oxide
emissions from the field
there's also a darker
a dark red color
which is indirect
emissions of nitrous oxide so this is
nitrogen that actually leaves the field
in some other form
chemical form
such as nitrate or ammonia
volatilization
and it's
but there are nitrous oxide emissions
associated with that nitrogen somewhere
after it leaves the farm field
it's small
there's also
a dark pink
portion of the bar which is the
production of synthetic nitrogen so as
i've mentioned several times there are
substantial emissions associated with
nitrogen fertilizer production
then there are emissions associated with
lime
production of the lime
equipment and fuel
this
particular analysis does not include any
change in soil carbon
so this is not looking at a change in
practice it's just an average emission
from new york corn production corn grain
production unfortunately as you see in
this quote
nitrous oxide emissions are are
increasing
and in fact they've exceeded some of the
previous emission scenarios so this is
really an urgent issue at the global
scale
so in agriculture we can make a
contribution to this
so the basic issue is
that only about half of the nitrogen
fertilizer we apply often goes into the
crop
and the rest is going to go somewhere
else a small amount of it can be emitted
as nitrous oxide but it's so potent that
it's an important greenhouse gas it can
also
be leeched as nitrate and and it can
pollute
groundwater or surface waters it can be
emitted as ammonia and and create air
pollution issues
so improving nitrogen management
can improve profitability first of all
if we can reduce
fertilizer use use it more efficiently
and maintain crop yield
and we can get benefits for water
quality air quality and soil health
so how can we
achieve these kinds of emissions so i
showed one example of
precision nitrogen
management
previously and how can we actually
accomplish that
well many of you are familiar with the
four r's of fertilizer management the
right source
rate time and place
so that gives us
the goal
but we need tools to help us achieve
that goal
and one such tool is adapt n i'm not
going to describe it
in any specifics
but it's been developed here in new york
state
and it allows you to use a web-based
platform
to put in information from your field
and use recent weather data to get a
specific side dress nitrogen
recommendation for corn
and these kinds of tools
can help achieve these four r's of
maintaining or increasing crop yield and
reducing nitrogen losses including
nitrous oxide emission
in many cases this can improve
profitability because we're improving
nitrogen use efficiency
so
i'm going to talk a little bit now about
a field experiment
with manure and cover crops
i'm not going to talk about compost and
biochar
but i just want to mention those are
other ways that organic matter
can be added to soil
those of you who are in the live
room today
will get the benefit of presentations
this afternoon and tomorrow on this
topic
so what happens to nitrous oxide
emissions when you add a lot of carbon
and nitrogen
to crop cropping system as manure
or as a legume cover crop
i'm going to talk about one
recent publication from pennsylvania
looking at
an organic
long-term experiment
so again this is a well-drained silt
loam soil
and the crop rotation
there were multiple crop rotations in
this experiment including corn both for
grain and silage soybean and spelt
a winter grain
the treatments
included different types of tillage
different cover crops different manure
management and the authors stated that
these
variations were typical of regional
organic agriculture
so this is a complicated graph
showing
some key results so i'll talk you
through this graph
on the vertical axis is nitrous oxide
emission
so the higher up we go from blue to red
is showing higher nitrous oxide
emissions
and at the highest amount
uh if we translate the units from what's
shown here which is
emissions per day
at an annual scale the highest amount
here caused an emission of five tons
of carbon dioxide equivalent per hectare
per year as nitrous oxide
if you remember from our examples of
from the fast ghg tool of improving
management
we were getting a fraction of a ton
benefit
so
so at the highest amounts here these are
very high amounts of nitrous oxide
emission
on the right bottom axis is manure
residue so this is the dry tons of
manure that were added
and if you follow the curve
on the rightmost part of this
colored graph
you can see that as you increase manure
from zero to two
almost up to four there's very little
increase in nitrous oxide emission but
once you get to four and above you get a
rapid increase in nitrous oxide
emission
which then levels off
similarly on the left hand bottom axis
is the legume residue so again this is
the amount of legume biomass that's
being added
and the scale is different
so when you go from
adding a little bit of residue
one ton
of residue there's very little in
nitrous oxide emission but as you exceed
two tons
of residue again you get a very steep
increase
in nitrous oxide emission
and the left most edge of this graph is
showing what happens
with the addition of legume without any
manure
so even so
without adding
any inorganic fertilizer and without
adding any manure you can get
quite high emissions of nitrous oxide
from a legume cover crop
if we add
a lot of
cover crop residue and a lot of manure
we get into the red area shown here
where you get an even greater amount of
nitrous oxide emission
so so what's going on here
this graph is the same experiment
and it's showing the importance of
different factors in contributing to
nitrous oxide emission so the top factor
is the amount of manure residue
so that's the most important factor in
the model
the next most important one
is called co2 flux here and what this
means is emission of carbon dioxide from
the field
which is an indication of soil activity
and microbial activity in the soil
this is important however because
the authors
show this and other evidence in the
paper that
by adding a lot of organic matter at the
same time that you're adding nitrogen
you can actually create conditions
where you get more nitrous oxide
emission
so specifically those conditions are a
lack of oxygen in the soil
that's when you get high nitrous oxide
emissions
so what this graph is showing is that
adding soil carbon
increases carbon dioxide emission and
also can increase nitrous oxide emission
so here are three take-home messages
from this experiment
adding organic matter can increase
nitrous oxide emissions
a second we want to make sure never to
add excess nitrogen
as inorganic fertilizer
as we saw previous examples
or in manure and legumes
and in terms of managing the cover crops
we might consider a mixture of grass and
legume cover crops especially when we're
also
using manure in the system
so i'm going to touch on a few
important topics
about the
the overall topic of greenhouse gas
emissions uh from cropping systems
and i hope you got to hear jennifer
whiteman's previous talk where
uh she went into these in greater detail
for carbon sequestration to work the
carbon
must not be released back to the
atmosphere so does this happen with
tillage and cover crops
i'll let you think about that for a
moment
and talk about permanence some
strategies are permanent
like preventing greenhouse gas emission
with reduced tractor passes or with
precision nitrogen fertilizer use
other strategies are not permanent but
they may have other benefits such as
adding organic matter to soil
so the benefit of of cover crops or the
benefit that just focus on tillage
part of the benefit is permanent in that
we've reduced tractor passes
part of the benefit that's due to soil
carbon sequestration
is not permanent
so it's
in
and moving towards wrapping up here it's
it's really important to count all three
greenhouse gases
and because nitrous oxide is so much
more potent than carbon dioxide a little
bit of increased nitrous oxide can wipe
out any benefit
from salt carbon sequestration
if yield decreases
it can result in leakage which can cause
high greenhouse gas emissions somewhere
else
so i won't
spend much time on this
slide
but again we need to be thinking about
practices that are permanent
real
as well as verifiable
so we don't want
leakage where emissions get shifted to
another location
so here are the five uh
take away messages from from my talk
today
i'm not going to read every every word
here but just again say permanence is is
important
uh we need to pay attention to an
avoiding uh reduction in yield
nitrogen dominates emissions from from
crops so we need to play pay close
attention to
the better management of nitrogen
fertilizer as well as manure and legumes
and again the bottom line is we really
need to look at the net greenhouse gas
benefit
uh
when we're thinking about the benefits
of any any practice
i have some literature cited that you
can
[Music]
access later if you're interested
and again want to acknowledge support
from usda and others for our previous
work
lastly
we as
jennifer mentioned previously we have
upcoming webinars in this series in the
18th of november and the 16th of
december and you can
get further information about that at
our website
thanks very much
so we should have time for some
questions now and i believe we will
start
joe with questions from the live
audience for a few minutes
um peter we had a question about more
periodic use of cover crops
because a lot of farms maybe they can
get it in after wheat but
maybe it's not possible every year or
the weather weather dependent
so let me make sure i'm understanding so
the question is
if you have a crop rotation
there may be some times in the rotation
where cover crops work well and other
times in the rotation where they don't
is is that the
is that the issue
yeah so uh
there are a lot of variables that have
to be addressed in implementing
practices
i guess what i would say is
there are many reasons why cover crops
might not be implemented every year but
if you implement them in the times that
make sense within
the weather and the cropping system
uh even if you implement them only uh
some of the years you will still get
some cumulative benefit from that
uh obviously there's also an interaction
with with
tillage you know how much
soil carbon benefit you'll get from that
practice
but yeah there's a lot of complexity in
managing cover crops
as as many of you know better better
than i do but timing of
of
of
terminating the cover crop before the
main crop is planted
you know attending to that carefully to
make sure you're not getting a reduction
in yield there are a lot of details to
be attended to
so i don't know if i hope i'm answering
the question at least a little bit
i guess in summary i would say
using cover crops
when they are maintaining or improving
yield of the main crops uh
is a great strategy even if it can't be
done every year
the other thing i'll i'll add in is
if there's an opportunity to add a crop
rather than a cover crop that is not
used for any
any uh
direct you know it's not harvested for
any purpose
you know always looking for the
opportunities to have a winter crop
whether it could be harvested for forage
or
or harvested as a product
you know that's an important thing to
look at as well since those winter crops
can provide some of the benefits of a
cover crop but you're also getting
additional production
any other questions
but we mentioned um
requires
a verifiable data would be collected
although
the session has already been making a
comprehensive life ledger system
something like blockchain
that could be uh
account for
all the changes and eventually expanded
globally
such a comprehensive
system directly like that
um peter the question was um
kind of what what is verification with
the clcpa what's that going to look like
on the ground is it going to be
state employees extension people is it
going to be
private groups a little bit on that
ah sure
um
i think the short answer is i don't know
and i don't think anyone else knows um
i'm i'll say a little bit more and then
give the opportunity uh jennifer if you
want to chime in
uh
so this
the state is focusing now on trying to
understand what are the mitigation
options in agriculture and every other
sector and how might they encourage
adoption of those practices
so
i don't know of specific plans that the
state has
other than the ongoing greenhouse gas
inventory
i think at the state level
the inventory will be a tool for trying
to account for the changes in greenhouse
gases over time
as jennifer mentioned that will always
be looking backwards a bit
if there are
direct payments made to farmers for
implementing practices i think that's
where
it's likely there may be some
requirements for verification
and as i say i don't think anyone knows
what that would look like
now
i'll just chime in and say i agree the
inventory sets the baseline and that's
really important for the beginning of
measurement and then
after you have the baseline and you have
these tools to measure
then you can get to verification but it
we are far away from that and i will
just say
that um
i think that reggie probably doesn't
allow offsets right now because partly
because of this problem in order to
ensure
that real mitigation is achieved
verification is very complicated in that
sense
and um
and
you know some of the voluntary offset
markets
require the
person who is making the offset to pay
the third party verifier so even though
you might be earning
15
a ton from a voluntary third party
system right now
you have to hire a third party verifier
so there's all kinds of things that
haven't been found haven't been figured
out
and that's why we're trying to advocate
for
real and permanent mitigation strategies
so that the verification is quite simple
requires very little
effort because they're so clearly doing
the job as we get more sophisticated of
course we can get we can start
addressing things that are more nuanced
like
you know all of the the variables that
peter talked about in his talk
i do want to add one more piece here
that
verification
is
depends on the scale that you're talking
about so so far we've been talking only
about verification at the field scale
that is very difficult and expensive
however at the state scale
or the national scale
there are less expensive opportunities
i think for verification
so for example we can use satellite
remote sensing to detect
how many farms in new york and in the us
are using winter cover cropping
and we can also use
satellite remote sensing to get a pretty
good idea of
some major differences in tillage
practices
and the issues of making a prediction
with a model for a specific field as i
mentioned our fast greenhouse gas model
and many other models are intended to
give the right answer as an average
value across many farms and fields and
they do a much better job of that than
they do at making a prediction for a
specific field
so this is all to say
that the job of estimating
the benefit of soil health practices
across new york state over time
that's an easier job than quantifying
the benefit in a specific field
so that's just an important kind of
spatial scale issue it's still not easy
at the state scale
but it is uh it is much easier
and less costly uh than doing it for
every single field
peter last question since we're thinking
about cover crops and no-till and
who can get paid for those types of
things what about the maybe
the farmers that have been at cover
cropping and no-tilling for a long time
and already have soil organic carbon
levels much higher
how can you have any thoughts on how
[Music]
they might have
sure so i think the question here is
kind of
if
if the state or anyone else is rewarding
farmers for a specific behavior
practice
to provide benefits to all of society
there's there's a question about what
about the people who are ahead of the
curve and already adopted these
practices and have been doing them for
years or decades shouldn't they be
getting some benefit
and this is not really a greenhouse gas
accounting question
um
this is really kind of an equity
question about
how do we support farming
and
so
i don't feel like i have any uh
particular professional
information to offer about you know
what's a fair result there i think this
is a question for all the citizens of
new york if we are going to pay
uh farmers
for a greenhouse gas benefit how are we
going to have a system that does that in
a way that is
that is real and permanent and also is
equitable for the farmers
thanks peter
great job
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu